leave again lights out crowd chance
prince prince back on stage rock out
another 20 25 minutes prince chris
media
it's a news overload
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey what's up it's hannibal burst ha
ha look when i scream the light changes
that's how we kicking off the show out
here you know what it is
quarantine life post covic and we out
here
screaming flick the lights
so we out here man just living life
ah what is the meaning
of everything we live in hell
everybody's gonna die but we gotta live
for the day
try to not catch the cold it's a news
overload thing is going
all right if i only did this show by
myself
we would run the risk of me just doing
this
the entire time gotta talk to my friend
aljax brian babylon marx price tony
[ __ ] byron bowers
first up tony trump
all right enough enough how's it been in
the shot man i haven't been home
man it's been it's been weird it's been
it's been strange
um it's been lively there's a lot of
good stuff going on there's a lot of
change happening you know i'm just
i've just been kind of keeping it chill
like i've been just cooking a lot
and just you know just doing my thing i
picked up this little guy today
okay fresh dog yeah this is nacho queso
new dog
[Music]
anyways yeah i want to go to l.a man in
denver
denver denver we got
al jackson yeah you do what's cracking
man
bruh nothing and everything man there's
a chinese saying may you live in
interesting times and
and damn it we doing it right yeah man i
just got my first uh you know
i got a crib out here uh shout out to
denver i got a ring
finally like one of them doorbells we
had it for like
a week and uh yo we got we had our first
visitor
on our porch uh yes so this this my crib
and it's a white girl look like she's
going to sarah mclaughlin concert
going through my [ __ ] yeah and what she
just went through
that's a royal crest uh your boy got
basically
uh two 2020 milkman yeah
they travel every thursday they drop off
bacon sausage
and uh like oat milk and stuff which is
good because it cuts down on you having
to go to the uh
grocery store but yeah she uh she she
crept up and is going through there
and i was like you know because my
immediate you know when [ __ ]
first started going down covered i went
i bought some things for home protection
you know i got a i got a machete which
you can buy you know you
might need to clear a little brush and
uh you know i got some bear spray
and so my first thing is like yo
if you catch somebody on your ring can
you bare spray them
on your porch which is i think is a fair
co you ain't talking about like
busting an ar-15 just a beer spray bro
and it's just like first of all let's be
honest i really
don't care about you stealing my oat
milk i just want to see what bear spray
does to somebody
[Music]
i just wanna see what happens
[Music]
is
[Music]
marcus was the one always wrangling
ballerinas
you don't get margaret marcus yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
marcus marcus obviously a lot of
businesses are doing
different types of corrections and it's
it's a very fascinating time
i just found out about this through you
you're like i want to talk about
starbucks you know like what's going on
with starbucks
so just yesterday they put out a a
basically an internal letter to their
employees saying
that they were not allowed to wear
anything that showed support
of black lives matter yeah so this is
when they said don't wear right
right and internal memo went to
starbucks employees
warning staffers against wearing
accessories of clothes bearing messages
and support
why'd they do that yeah so
and and then today almost
you know right when we wake up they have
a new notice saying that basically
saying oh we we encourage diversity and
encourage
our employees to express themselves in
whatever way they think so
cover-up flip it slap it flip it flip it
flop it
flip it slap it flip it flip it fluff it
flopping
flip flopping and you're stuck prices
popping look the stock went up five
percent
today yeah damn because
there was this happened and then there
was the whole uh
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer with the
the kente cloth kneeling
i feel like that we just like there's
like the federal trade commission and
like the usd stamped organic there's
certain certifications i think that we
need to create
just a group of maybe a dozen black
folks or people of color
just to be be available to these
companies to be like nah dog you
shouldn't do that
i like the gq angle on it nancy pelosi
and the end of fashion diplomacy
oops she did it again begins the article
okay
i'm out of there mate all right
really this job could be solved with
just maybe you know
three black folks buying bows what's
cracking man
yo what's up man you ain't got the trump
email
you know i've been getting byron bowers
some of the other byron bowers emails
for the past
you know five years you know i mean like
i see one buyer
in austin um i know his kids got
accepted to a private school i know he's
married to his architect
she's indian descent it's another buyer
in chatham county
uh georgia which is where uh my
ancestors
entered georgia i get a trump email like
congratulations buyer for joining the
team
and i was like oh [ __ ] which byron
bowers
is this and i sent you the email
yeah well i got one today just on my own
email
i don't know if he jack somebody list or
something
but is it hannibal democrats are
energizing their socialist base
take our one question poll to let trump
know he can counter your vote in 2020.
who will you vote for in 2020 president
trump or a socialist democrat
and then you click on the follow i
thought this [ __ ] was fake
because it said who you vote for
president trump or sleepy joe biden i yo
what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you man insults
insults you know what i mean you know
the countries and crisis is a global
pandemic and you're like sleepy joe
biden like
what is wrong with you dog let me let me
kick it to you where i'm at
look his son [ __ ] yeah i get
i'm a part of already dead this byron
already gave to the
to the to the cause he already knows
he's heavy in there yeah so he's in look
sign my father's uh birthday card
[Music]
trump in oakland his birthday card
yeah that's the truth
[Laughter]
where you been i need your help we're
making a card to celebrate our father's
birthday on june 14th
yeah where have i been wow that's
fascinating
all right man babylon babylon what's
crackin man
hey man what's up what's going on dog
you know how people talk about what do
we do
with this cop situation yeah people
saying defund the police some people
saying this
i have a four-prong approach that i'm
gonna go
you ready number one right we need to
have federal
and local law enforcement focus on
dismantling
organized crime first and foremost
because organized crime
fuels street crime like because you know
you know you've heard
you know uh boys in the hoods always you
know i'm saying how did the dru
guns get into our neighborhoods or how
do drugs get in our neighborhoods
there's clearly
a white kid going to college somewhere
in the suburbs and they daddy a drug
dealer and they don't have no clue
that's the kind of [ __ ] i'm talking
about okay number two
a total rip up an overhaul of
all police contracts because they have
been bogus
from the start from the 50s and 40s and
people have been piled on [ __ ]
no union involvement because a lot of
those union rules
make it easy for cops to do [ __ ] and
not get caught you know like with their
with their back history you can't find
out there's a lot of those bogus as
union rules right you know number three
of course
more more real jobs that could be in the
community
you know working jobs where someone with
not a lot of education
or you know not low wage jobs a
moderately waste jobs for people to work
but then lastly this is the one that
might be a little
controversial there needs to be another
element by the people
where there needs to be some type of
phoenix jones if you will
or biblical batman justice
on cops who do bogus [ __ ] so if i see
you on tape with your neck on somebody's
neck
we all see it phoenix knee on somebody's
neck
yeah anything bogus like you know the
cops would beat up rodney king or like
any air gardener
if you get caught doing some [ __ ] and we
see it and the system
doesn't get you bible justice slash
phoenix phoenix jones black batman i
don't give a [ __ ] what you call it
that needs to be an element where cops
know like ooh
if the law don't get me candy man wheel
there needs to be another
element out there but i'll cut that [ __ ]
out
in a pitch how many times how many times
can you say [ __ ]
what's the what's the sweet spot i came
up
with a show off the movie big with a
black lead
of a little boy little innocent boy go
to the fortune teller
and wake up a grown ass [ __ ] with no
job and he got a walk
he gotta deal with the police and all
type of [ __ ] you know what i mean
bidding war wish to be a kid again
i wonder if i could sell that in the
room yeah
i keep getting this video from this dude
yeah
that people are sending me that's like
yo man
if you get this video somebody care
about you
you should send this video out this one
right here
yeah hey listen man i'ma keep this short
and sweet if you watching this right now
is because somebody five million views
you want to see you win damn
period five minutes never heard of them
and i'm telling people now like man [ __ ]
this [ __ ] man
if you care about me you make a video
for me
let me send me a video of another [ __ ]
that i don't know this [ __ ] this
dude straight i don't know this dude
never heard of him
this might respect you somebody's
checking up on your man
right now god goddess god is the
greatest
we the best no wait
wait who's the best him oh god he said
god is the greatest
we the best
well the best and the greatest are two
different things right
i think they're synonymous man no
they say muhammad ali is the greatest
boxer is really not too many people in
that category
they'll say like floyd mayweather is the
best yeah
but muhammad ali is the greatest that's
two different
that's two different things like they
say some people say like it's people
with better stats than jordan but jordan
is
the greatest greatest yeah no i agree i
agree like best you can be the best at
the time i feel like that's more of a
temporary thing like he's the best right
now
but the greatest that means like he he's
in the hall of fame
like he's transferred the best best
sounds like something
that you get at a state fair
[Laughter]
well think about hip-hop though like you
could say that you know like hands-down
insert name here like locksmith or
somebody's the is the is the best
lyricist but he was never in a
discussion as the greatest
like the greatest gotta like have you
got to have club bangers
you got to have songs girls you got to
have some
songs dudes like to smoke you got to be
able to do everything really well
so does everyone agree does anyone have
an argument for that maybe the best
could be the greatest i hear yeah yeah
this is
you know i was i was wrong i just
started thinking about
dj khaled saying we're the best over and
over
yeah that makes me believe it less yeah
i have a question and i'm curious about
are
are white strangers treating you
different i didn't like i went to go get
some tacos
and some do just was like power to the
people at me you know
i don't like some 50 year old i don't
know
what ethnicity was but these tacos
see i was trying to save time not
getting delivery
doing pickup instead and then i have
bound to the people i'm like oh
that's it's too weird out here man what
about white people like
i feel like somebody when i was uh
on the road in between arizona and l.a i
went to my sisters
yeah and uh
somebody i feel like somebody held the
door at the gas station longer than they
needed
she's like an older woman she looked
like she wants
yeah dude the lady by the steps yeah
what about this i don't what
oh no she's been going after asians so
tony better watch out
you need to go home i am from here look
at
go home i am here from here i don't care
about your facebook or your video
you play games we don't play games oh
what kind of game are you playing
i play games where you get [ __ ] to
death
oh [ __ ] to death
you are going to go to real jail now
respect respect people oh
man her dress looks like the inside of
an
oven mitt like
they put her whole [ __ ] up here lena
hernandez
is 54 years old she's waiting to
hernandez
she's probably married to a hispanic
dude or something so that right some of
that rage is coming from somewhere else
she manages the carl's jr [ __ ] that's
the most funny thing
of the whole [ __ ] it's funny how like
because it's like the white
like the white racism towards asians
it's not really hate it's more like
ridicule and like it's white people
going like hold on hold on no nothing
like trying to be like
funny but it's not funny it's just
offensive but it's more like
they ridicule you to feel small you know
it's not
it's not the same kind of uh racism
towards black folks where it's like
hostile and like
obviously like a lot of hate-filled [ __ ]
but with asians it's more like
hey get back in your place china man you
know what i'm saying i wish old boy had
some heaters
for yeah exactly that's what i was
waiting like just
roast the [ __ ] off that dumb ass [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] man
you could have said something funny
witty
you know
like you got so much to work with
get it together police id woman and
raise this tire a hundred percent on
terrorist fraud for workout
what is that it's just a couple days
oh she's talking to somebody else listen
to me
we don't play games here anymore okay
next time you ever talk to me like that
you're gonna get your ass kicked by my
family
they're gonna [ __ ] you up what do i do
they're gonna
[ __ ] you why what did i do because you
are an [ __ ] at this same the whole
stairs
go back to whatever [ __ ] asian
country you belong in
okay racist [ __ ] [ __ ] there's other
stairs you are a sick [ __ ]
ignorant teenager oh thank you [ __ ]
what middle-aged woman
who wears black in california
you're reaching out you're reaching
yeah she was out there and she was done
if you got some good [ __ ] burners and
you roast the [ __ ] out of her
then she's gonna [ __ ] come at you
with physical attacks
and then that's when you whoop that ass
she's definitely mentally ill
it's [ __ ] up it's weird she went to
the black
and that's her wrote like this to be
going at people and that's you
who wears black and cali well get the
what
man dresses as grim reaper to warn
florida beach goers about coronavirus
yeah i saw this i like that i'm dressed
as the grim
reaper yeah or dealing with a deadly
body i think it's too soon
to draw thousands of millions of people
who wears black in the florida
he would have roasted the [ __ ] out of
her dog oh yeah
one thing i thought was real interesting
man i want to get y'all perspective on
this
is like uh with the with the karen they
got slapped at the gas station to slap
her around the world
it's like this was the first time
because i i was so sure i was going to
see like
equal pushback because you know there's
like the the devil's advocate people on
social media that's always like well
you know what she said wasn't right but
the slap wasn't cool either
i didn't see any of that that was like
one of the only universal things like
everybody's like yo
she kept pushing it dude just put
phoenix karen
phoenix i was in phoenix no here he is
excuse me but you did say that she needs
to go back to her country what kind of
what kind of what is that
native american excuse me this is what
this whole world people are not from
this country
you don't deserve her yeah
to also also
also this white lady got a fat ass
continue
get a little thick
[Laughter]
white confidence is acting like
security when you got no squabbles you
got no
hands yeah you
just like you thinking you could just
tell [ __ ] to get up
out of there when you ain't when you
ain't got
nothing to make [ __ ] truly get
out except for your voice and energy
is like [ __ ] we even have a flashlight
it doesn't even mean
the sunglasses is a [ __ ] that do
support
and swear and call me a [ __ ]
i know i said she is and that's why
she's leaving so you will leave too
this is going on oh she walked off like
it's done
the day is done and so i said it so
but like was like took care of that she
should have dusted her hands like all
right that's one down
oh she's walked off like she just
knocked the [ __ ] out on streaks
of rage or some [ __ ]
[Music]
internet you don't know who i am you
told her you told her to go back to her
country
where she's from
that's a song yeah i know that right
where are your ancestors from you're not
from this country
you're going back to mexico [ __ ] you
better go back to where you're
from you just know you just walked into
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh my god oh my goodness
yeah you pushed her and she smacked you
that was you know self-defense
the white guy narrating really diffuses
the situation
yeah i don't be on facebook like that so
i want to check the vibes on
the comments uh that slap was so
satisfying to watch that woman is
disgusting and so entitled
hope she gets kicked off whatever job
she has she can't be around other humans
honestly
[Music]
thank you for standing up for speaking
out let's see
uh
[Music]
saw her husband on the news trying to do
damage control claiming she has an
undiagnosed mental illness that she
refuses to get treatment
if you thought she really had a mental
illness he would have had her
involuntary treated for her own
protection
and a protection of others so miss me
with that bs
yeah and yeah for real because the
husband was on there
crying dog it's a it's a pr he starts
you can't claim
yeah you can't take the insanity plea on
this one i'm sorry
it's not gonna work worked at his office
cuz so how crazy could she be
she shows up every day and leaves every
day that's pure
that was pure white entitlement you
you've been playing some
nba 2k yes
when i won that ship dog because i
i don't know worked so hard at it you
know what i'm saying i've been doing the
workouts
in the little in the little gym i've
been hitting the part
i've been putting that work in and then
when you make it
when you win a championship with a small
market squad
[Laughter]
because 2k has been such a big part of
my world
during this time i i got emotional for
you i was like yo he did
it dawg i was really you said it
i called you
[Laughter]
[Music]
i hit up percy i say your percy babylon
[Laughter]
i let babylon want to chip on 2k
i said percy was like yo here's my
player is my player look just like him
man
and i was like oh [ __ ] quarantine really
joe [ __ ]
crazy because now i played that much 2k
with that is like that like yeah man he
worked hard at the game
put that on tell everybody about that uh
black lives matter rally in 2k
let's see uh what is
what marcus so this is this is this
[ __ ] is in
they're playing the game around the
country yeah
but this is this is the park so that's
where you play with people
everybody just went running through yeah
they're rude
i was gonna ask cause y'all play online
do people because i heard people say
racist stuff on call of duty do people
say stuff like that in in 2k
i i like that you brought that up
because that's the main reason like in
the early days of like all those
first-person shooters
i couldn't get into it because it would
just be little kids saying the craziest
[ __ ] they'd be like i'm coming after you
china man
i don't know how they know your chinese
because my name my username was
chinaman346
[Laughter]
my call next get out of here you monkey
[Applause]
uh hannibal contested this i balled in
front of him out of college before
yeah i was there that was in san diego
right yeah
yeah i remember that and they didn't
like they didn't like me
from the get-go what happened yeah that
[ __ ] was funny i just started man and i
just
i think the name of that school mascot
was the aztecs
yeah san diego state yeah how was y'all
name out of school after
a distinct people they got slaughtered
you know i mean
how y'all expect to win games that's how
i open you know
byron in your defense they did have like
a [ __ ] booty shaking concert
or like contest right before you
oh you can't follow booty shake energy
no you know you can't do it especially
being like
sarcastic and these people are like
freshmen and they they haven't even seen
the world yet
and then uh i tried to save the set and
it got long
and long and i remember snapping on
people
yeah i remember walking off stage
and hannibal was backstage he's like why
the [ __ ] did you just stay on stage
you know why did you just get off stage
and i looked at it i was like
i thought i could get them back but i
told somebody i remember telling
somebody
i was like man i made it already i
graduated
i'm gonna have you [ __ ] ain't gonna
even make it
somebody booed and i just snapped i was
like the person that booze you're gonna
be doing nails in three weeks i'm not a
comic but that's gotta be
uh experience muscling through this hate
like that
just the whole audience hating you
marcus let me tell you what it's like
hit me i got my ass whooped in school
one time
as the people were going to lunch so
they was walking by looking in the
mirror
i mean looking through the window of the
assistant principal office as i was
getting my ass with
and the lady turned the blinds like this
and like a glimpse of hope just faded
right wait who was whooping your ass my
mom came
to the school i got in trouble oh yeah
just back in the day
in the in the office yeah and black
black vice principal so she just was
like enjoying it right
and um that's what
would it feel like the bomb is to get
get to go through that and they have to
go back to class
after that and act like they act like
nothing happened why people try to talk
to you about that [ __ ]
did i ever tell you by the time i bombed
on a cruise ship
and the dude emailed me this i just do
an
audience emailed me dog i uh
dude this is early in my career i won um
emailed you on the cruise he emailed me
when i got home i guess
he still enjoyed his vacation and hit me
later but
that that made it worse that mean he
thought about it for four days and he's
like i gotta
find this dude's contact info i got home
i opened up my email
and i never forget the subject line just
said
cruise ship bomb and bomb was
b dot o dot m dot b
like that was just such
like and he was like you're on your way
to recovering yeah and it was like
so hurtful because he was so
disappointed in me like a dad would be
he was like
my wife and i were excited just to go to
your show we ate dinner at the early
dinner seating so we could make it to
the 8 30
comedy show we have been a fan of yours
and we're anxious to hear you talk
little did we know and then it just went
off
how sad his wife was and just like i
felt so bad dude i was like dude
babylon what's your craziest chicago
show story
oh jokes and notes probably yeah i think
that was one with me you did we did we
didn't do hot
and i was feeling myself that was the
black club i was feeling myself
and i i went over there for the first
show
and i had on a windbreaker tied around
my waist
with a hat turned backwards
i went up on stage full tony hawk
came out with a eating out joke to some
black people
and while the headliner was up he said
come here
what the [ __ ] was that first of all
[ __ ] you go home and change
and then the other time uh this is in
london when i bombed
with uh [ __ ] i came out with a joke
it was an acon joke and it was a joke
about hey y'all
don't a kind sound like an african robot
that [ __ ] was killing her jokes and
notes
in london what do you mean african robot
like amer you know oh
man and then i started talking about hey
what's up with the white girls
and then i heard in the back
you're rubbish man
oh that would have hurt me to my soul i
was like
i had a question have you all ever been
on a show
uh a run of shows at a club
and been swapped because the shows
weren't going well
or have you been killing so much where
they bumped you up that's it yeah i uh i
went to afghanistan
and i bombed um
i was doing jokey jokes in my medieval
time it was i was seven years in the
game
and i just realized i was funny and then
i went to afghanistan in 2012
and uh they had a show at one o'clock in
the afternoon
and i ate a dick they put me up for
anything i gotta go first man it's just
not good
on those type of shows and uh it was
like four of us
and i everybody did relationship jokes
except me
and uh i ate a dick and then uh we had
another show that night
and i remember sitting in the barracks
and i just said hello
you know what i mean and um i was like
uh
hey man you just realized you was funny
[ __ ] them jokes
and then i went out [ __ ] and just
did me and it it i murdered standing
ovation
and i got reprimanded from command
because apparently
you know i fisted [ __ ] on stage i did
all type of [ __ ] like it was my true
self
so i went from talking about medieval
times to like ain't no [ __ ] on this
[ __ ] how about jack off like this you
know
yeah so every show every time i went to
another base they was like man we heard
about you
but everyone man i would get in trouble
for just you know just just
unleashing and i was talking about
government on you yeah so i was just
talking about everything i experienced
while i was there
you know and uh and then uh the last
show
i i was like i'm just gonna not say
anything too reckless
i'm just gonna get my check and leave
and uh
i did the show and then the soldiers
came up to me and i got reprimanded by
the soldiers for not going hard
because everything they go through there
that i experienced that i was talking
about
that [ __ ] they want to complain about
but they would they can't
and the dude told me man we out here
doing [ __ ] we
we're not even questioning what we doing
he basically saying we murdered
[ __ ] for no reason but
he was like we do our duties so you do
yours when you come over hannibal you
ever been swapped out
not swapped out nah
um i had my time
cut early on and i've been played off
stage
without warning before i've been played
off stage
on a on a book show like
not on a apollo or a
gong show like dj played the music i'm
like this is a
this is a three act it's just host
middle and the headliner and that dj was
playing music i was like damn
damn man but did any of y'all ever get
cut cut on some haters [ __ ] like you
were killing it too hard
and then like whoever you're opening for
was just yes nah
yes yeah
yeah i mean that's the wacko [ __ ] i hate
when people do that it's like let the
[ __ ] finish i don't mind saying
the name
had me fired off a show when i was a uh
in florida because he had a bunch of
racist jokes he felt like he couldn't
tell this back when i was a house mc
down in south florida
and uh he used to have like a joke about
like
you know you know black kids in in in
school they're always like where's my
ink pen he's like one of those guys that
never updated his
black guy voice oh yeah yeah and so he
hey
brother what it is one time you know
that kind of
he just thinks that's every black dude
and so like
and and and and mexican people sticky
with switchblades
hey chica you're gonna give me your
purse you see yeah
[ __ ] that was a terrible mexican
not even puerto rican you should take
you should take uh accent classes from
that from that white lady who was making
fun of that asian person
that's the end of the show so
leave again lights out crowd chance
prince prince
back on stage rock out another 20 25
minutes prince
chris
i still live in media